beginning with the first Star Wars film
in 1977 and spanning nine full-length
motion pictures the Skywalker saga is
over 40 years old between the new hope
and the rise of Skywalker there are
still plenty of questions left
unanswered fair warning
major spoilers for the rise of Skywalker
and the mandalorian lie ahead in the
first entry in the most recent trilogy
the force awakens we learned the
diminutive Maz Kanata somehow has Luke's
first lightsaber the one obi-wan Kenobi
gives him in a new hope band that
originally belonged to his father Anakin
pawn ask Maz how she got it and she
answers only a good question for another
time
well whatever another time means it's
outside the skywalker saga the rise of
skywalker ends with luke's first light
saber alongside Leia's buried near
luke's old home on Tatooine it's a
question not easily answered Luke loses
his first lightsaber when Darth Vader
chops off his hand during their
climactic duel at the end of the Empire
Strikes Back in Cloud City above the
planet best spin luke's hand and his
weapon fall down the same long shaft
Luke drops down himself the planet
Mazdas Tavern is on as Taco Donna in a
completely different system from best
spent it isn't unthinkable the saber
could find its way to Massa's hands
presumably someone found it and
eventually sold it to her maybe she
founded herself or maybe she acquired it
through less than legal means whatever
path it took we may never know we can't
really count the Mandalorian as part of
the Skywalker saga but the emergence of
the child better known as baby Yoda is
for now linked to the tiny Jedi Master
Yoda who appears both in person and
through Justice voice in most of the
Skywalker saga films fan theories spring
up almost immediately upon baby Yodas
appearance at the end of the
Mandalorians first episode with many
guessing the toddler is either a clone
of or directly related to Master Yoda on
one hand it's kind of silly to assume
the child has anything at all to do with
Yoda other than being members of the
same species after all if you're
introduced to a human character in a
Star Wars film you don't immediately
assume oh that must be Han Solo's nephew
come on let's keep a little optimism on
the other hand the assumption is
understandable since we know so very
little about Yoda and the child's
species we don't even know their species
is named yet switch George Lucas
purposely left out of mythology if
there's a deeper link between the two
likely have to wait until further
episodes of the mandalorian to learn it
since the hero himself is now searching
for the child's planet the Skywalker
saga offers no answers for now one of
the biggest surprises in the Star Wars
prequels was the discovery that it was
the young Anakin Skywalker who created
c-3po the protocol droids best friend
r2d2 appears in all three prequels as
well yet when obi-wan is reunited with
them in a new hope he doesn't seem to
recognize them and we never learned why
hello then of course the real reason is
most likely because the Phantom Menace
came out over 20 years after the first
Star Wars film and George Lucas had no
idea in 1977 the droids would appear in
any prequels but there are some possible
narrative explanations to it could be
that Kenobi does remember the droids but
is keeping that to himself these aren't
the droids you're looking for
after all he clearly doesn't want to
tell Luke about his father and
explaining his acquaintance to the
droids brings him closer to that
difficult truth it's also possible he
genuinely doesn't remember them Kenobi
isn't depicted in the earlier films as
being particularly attached to droids a
story in the Clone Wars shows Kenobi is
not nearly as concerned as Anakin when
r2d2 is presumed lost Anakin it's only a
droid you know attachment is not
acceptable for a Jetta and it can only
convince his his master to let him
rescue the droid by telling him their
sensitive military data in its memory
when Finn Rey and the other heroes
believe they're sinking to their deaths
and the rise of Skywalker Finn tries to
tell ray something but he never gets the
chance thankfully the hero survived and
when Ray ask Ben what he was going to
tell her he says he'll tell her later
Poe teases Finn about it but by the end
of the film we still haven't learned
whatever it was been meant to say the
most obvious assumption is that he was
going to profess his love for her the
two obviously cared for one another and
shortly after they meet in the force
awakens
Finn asks her pointedly if she has a
boyfriend got a boyfriend a boyfriend
none of your business that's why
according to a cinema blend report
quoting rise of Skywalker director and
co-writer JJ Abrams however Finn's
motivations may have been decidedly less
romantic rather than making a play for
Rey he was apparently going to confirm
something suggested repeatedly
throughout the sequel trilogy named
that he's force-sensitive there are two
big hints in the rise of Skywalker that
pin might have enough of a connection
with the forest to be trained as a Jedi
first there's when finishers fellow
reformed stormtrooper Janna that it was
the force that made it possible for his
true self to emerge from the first
orders conditioning or surprise together
later in the battle against the final
order fleet Finn says he knows the order
has transferred their navigation from
the ground tower to the command ship
only because he could feel it when we
think back to the force awakens there
were hints since the very beginning Finn
makes a memorable impression on kylo Ren
after the village is slaughtered in the
movies opening later when he escapes
with Poe kylo knows which stormtrooper
he was right away the one from the
village affirmed to 187 both moments
suggest Ben is either causing or being
affected by ripples in the force which
kylo feels as well meanwhile general
Hawkes and Captain phasma seem confused
since he had shown no prior signs of
nonconformity the rise of Skywalker ends
without any firm word either way but it
seems at least possible the man formerly
known as fn-2187 might be due a
lightsaber of his own the first time we
see a sip using Force Lightning is in
Return of the Jedi when Emperor
Palpatine nearly kills Luke Skywalker
with it since then it's been clear that
some SIF can use it while others can't
but it isn't really clear what governs
who gets to use it and who doesn't we
never see darth vader using force
lightning but considering how much of
his body is mechanical it's a safe
assumption that using it would be
dangerous to him but we also never see
Darth Maul use it supreme leader Snoke
never uses it as far as we know though
admittedly his death then the last Jedi
doesn't give us much chance to see what
he can or can't do kylo Ren doesn't
appear to be able to summon the stuff
and considering his temper and overall
lack of subtlety were pretty sure if he
could he would one might assume that
Sith masters like Palpatine purposely
refrained from teaching their students
how to use Force Lightning to make sure
they have an advantage should the
student try to kill them that wouldn't
explain how Count Dooku knows how to use
it nor how Rey without even consciously
trying summon sports lightning and the
rise of skywalker
even if you missed all the promotional
lead ups to the rise of skywalker
mentioning emperor palpatine s return
his resurrection is made clear in the
beginning of the film
what isn't answered at any
is exactly how the Sith master survived
his supposed death at the end of Return
of the Jedi and Revenge of the Sith
Palpatine says he knows how to bring the
dead back to life and uses his claim to
seduce Anakin Skywalker who was plagued
by premonitions of Padme death to the
dark side he could actually save people
from death still even if we assume
Palpatine is telling Anakin the truth
that doesn't explain how the Sith Lord
can resurrect himself particularly when
you consider the manner of his death the
dying Vader hurls Palpatine off a cat
walked down a long shaft and the Emperor
appears to explode when he reaches the
bottom we're not suggesting Palpatine's
resurrection is uniquely unlikely and a
narrative so full of making the
impossible possible but the rise of
Skywalker nevertheless fails to explain
exactly how he survives not only his
drop down that shaft but the destruction
of the second Death Star at the end of
the rise of Skywalker Rey uses the
strength of all the Jedi before her and
reflects Palpatine's power back at him
killing him but is he really dead
Palpatine's death seems pretty final at
the end of the rise of Skywalker we see
him blown to pieces but arguably his
death doesn't seem any more or less
final at the end of Return of the Jedi
if Palpatine can come back from
that'swhat can't he come back from
further complicating things is the fact
that we're never told exactly how
Palpatine survives Return of the Jedi if
we knew that we might see that somehow
the same or similar explanation doesn't
apply this time in the end it may be
best to assume that we don't know
whether or not this is really the end
for Palpatine or how many times
Palpatine has died or even which
Palpatine's have been the real Palpatine
in spite of the fact that he personally
trains obi-wan Kenobi he's the one who
finds Anakin Skywalker and he's the
first Jedi we see communicating from
beyond the grave qui-gon jinn is never
mentioned in the original trilogy or
even in the more recent films of the
Skywalker saga the only teacher Kenobi
mentions is Yoda and says he took it
upon himself to train Anakin never
mentioning that it was qui-gon dying
wish who is me
the real-world reason is probably no
more complicated than the fact that
George Lucas hadn't yet conceived of gin
in the original trilogy but no narrative
reason has been offered one possibility
is that not wanting him to learn the
identity of his father Kenobi and Yoda
chose to give Luke as few details as
possible it could also be that Jin's
reputation is spotty
after all he brings Anakin to the Jedi
and a lot of blood is spilled before
Anakin is redeemed the rise of Skywalker
finally answers the question of Rey's
parentage we learned she's the
granddaughter of Emperor Palpatine and
that her birth parents sold her into
servitude on jakku to save her from the
emperor after which her parents were
murdered by a jedi hunter the only
missing piece is rays grandmother
Emperor Palpatine isn't exactly a
stunning paragon of charisma so it's
natural to wonder exactly who agreed to
make a union with the Sith Lord the
prequels give us one possibility seen
often standing next to Palpatine in
attack of the clones and Revenge of the
Sith is a quiet pale and eerie looking
bald woman named slime or the official
Star Wars website describes her as quote
Palpatine senior administrative aide
during his chancellorship and says that
rumors surround the enigmatic woman the
expanded universe offers a couple of
other options though they're from
stories no longer considered canon in
the 1995 novel children of the Jedi by
Barbour Hambly reg andhe is Marin is
introduced the former Jedi youngling is
captured by the Empire and made
Palpatine's concubine
there's also Isan Izzard introduced in
the Dark Horse comic book series x-wing
Rogue Squadron
at one point is 'red is the director of
Imperial intelligence and actually takes
over leadership of the Empire after
Palpatine's death in Return of the Jedi
her position suggests she likely at one
point had a close relationship with the
emperor though anything romantic is left
to speculation check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]